I started off my career in science in
physics I had a great time in the
laboratory and studied chemistry and the
physics and lasers back in the dawn of
that work then I moved to planetary
astronomy and studied the moons of
Jupiter the surface of Mars and then I
got a chance to go into space myself
flew four missions on the US space
shuttles twice on Atlantis and twice on
Endeavour I tell people in the electric
power industry that I'm usually the only
one in the room who Oh is there life two
fuel cells and solar panels that gets
the conversation off the ground pretty
well with folks from industry folks who
are students and it's great to be able
to bring some of those kind of
perspectives to our problems in electric
power my work has three focuses one is
markets for electric power you know
Pennsylvania and California were the
first two states to restructure the
electric power industry in 1996 the
second is security and reliability of
the electric power system the third is
low carbon dioxide generation including
renewable power in electric power
markets when we published some research
that showed that consumer prices had not
been affected either down or up by
Electric Power restructuring that was
seminal work in other industries
railroads Airlines trucking barges the
prices had really gone way down after
deregulation not so in electric power
after we showed that not one state has
deregulated and we still have just the
20 states that have restructured and 30
heads so we really changed the tone of
the debate on electric power
restructuring in renewables and other
low carbon electric power we have done a
lot of work in the basic mathematics of
wind power and of solar power that shown
how you can best integrate those into
the exist
electric power system at lowest cost
we've also done work with electric
vehicles and done studies of storing
electric power and how that affects
markets and how markets affect the
profitability of storing electric power
you